this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the ramsey
shower this is the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host happy new year
are you ready
yeah yeah anything anything that puts
those other two years in the rearview
mirror is a good thing oh my gosh we're
loving it 2022. george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money how excited are you for
22. i'm pumped if it definitely feels
like a fresh start that we all needed
even if it's just a temporal date on the
calendar it feels like all right let's
start this thing over again let's see
what happens i'm really good with just
getting the eraser to the whiteboard
the clean whiteboard is a good playing
for me i just i can start fresh i'm good
with that i'm good with that and um
yeah uh the only good i mean with that
much manure there's you gotta you gotta
have some growth oh yeah so there's
gotta be some growth with the last two
years of manure so there's a pony in
there somewhere it's gotta be brother
gotta be well open phones as we talk to
you about your life your work your
relationships and your money george
campbell is again with me today as we
answer your questions we are excited
baby steps millionaires the book comes
out next week it is on pre-sale now i'll
be talking more about that as we go
along
and um back
from the holidays ready to work ready to
get things done a lot of energy around
this place today we got almost 1100
people at ramsey and they were all um in
their seats this morning for staff
meeting ready to go i was pumped to just
get my coffee here you know just get
back to some routine oh you just you
don't have to pay for the coffee exactly
are you free george no no dave i just
really like the coffee here it's
delicious and it happens to be free
that changes the taste but there is an
element to getting into your back into
routine
waking up at a certain time you know you
kind of lose your sense of self after
christmas so yeah we're happy to help
and take calls today that's it i'm tired
of being um
other people so i'm not ready to be
myself
that's that's one way to put it
travis is going to start the year off
from asheville north carolina travis
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you guys doing today better than
we deserve man what's up
i have a question for you um we are in
baby step six
um and i made a purchase last month and
i've been losing some sleep about
because i can't decide if i did the
right thing and i tried calling him last
month and you all were super busy so i'm
getting through today i'm either going
to get a tongue lashing or some
reassurance i'm not sure but i have a
question about a vehicle i bought
okay
um so i was looking for a truck for
months like two or three months i saved
up cash and with this crazy
market
everything that i was seeing
just seemed really high for a used truck
so i kept looking around and i finally
came across a deal a couple hours for me
on the truck that i wanted and it was
actually a new truck that was going for
about three grand less than the used
trucks of the same year like i was
looking at 2019 2020 gmc sierras and
they're going for around 55 grand for
the for the truck that i wanted and i
came across a 20 21 that was brand new
with factory rebates that had it down to
about 52 500 and it had to make a quick
move just because of this crazy market
so long story short i did end up
purchasing it even though it was new and
i know that you know that's not what we
do with the baby steps but i'm wondering
what this crazy market and the price you
know and the research that i did if if
this did make sense or if i should look
to maybe get rid of it and get into
something cheaper
well i have a real i don't start the
year with tongue license
the first caller of the year we can't do
it it's against one of the rules and so
so you pay 50 grand for a truck what do
you make of your household income
150 okay
and what's your net worth today
uh about 200 okay
all right
and 50 000 of it is in the truck going
down in value
yes
this is why we tell people not to buy
new vehicles
until you have a million dollars
one-fourth of your net worth is going to
be worth nothing in five years
right that's the problem with buying new
trucks i mean
if you're worth a million dollars you
can afford to lose 50 grand if you're
worth 200 000 50 grand a lot of your
life
that's the only point so it's not a
tongue action it's just an observation
man you're a grown man you make 150 000
a year you can go buy a truck if you
want to go buy a truck we're not going
to be mad at you we'll be friends
okay
so again no tongue lashings at the first
year but you're right that's why we
teach people
not to yeah and if i was travis i would
have looked at a car that was you know a
few years older than that and that's
where you are going to find something at
a cheaper price point when you look at a
2021 versus the 2022 and the used car
market right now i get that it's crazy
but i think like you're saying dave this
is just a huge percentage of his world
that's tied up in this depreciating
asset yeah i mean the thing is this you
need to ask yourself when you're buying
anything with wheels or a motor
if i set fire to it without insurance
it finishes burning
is my life changed dramatically when you
lose 25 percent of your net worth if you
set fire to it
that's pretty dramatic
you know it's five percent of your net
worth it's not
dramatic it's a ratio thing for me you
can do what you want to do but as long
as you lean into depreciating assets
being a large chunk of your world things
losing value
that are being a large chunk of your
world then you're going to struggle with
that and i did the exact same stuff
travis i mean we've all done it but you
knew better because you'd been taught
and you just figured out a way to
rationalize it well he was saying if he
would call it i wouldn't lose sleep over
it it's not going to cause you to go
bankrupt i'm not going to sit here and
shame you that's not the point the the
point is the reason we teach
not to buy a new car unless you're a
millionaire is this exact reason and it
can you know it comes from all things
when i got tongue by my grandpa i mean
he passed away now but um you know he
worked 38 years at alcoa aluminum head
cost accounting there in alcoa tennessee
down the mountains east tennessee and i
come wheeling up down there at
23 years old 24 years old with a million
dollar net worth driving a jaguar
and a bunch of real estate debt coming
out my ears just before i'm going broke
right
and and uh i was all proud of my jaguar
well grandpa from east tennessee didn't
even know what jaguar was he's like what
is his car
and i told him and he's like shaking his
head he was not impressed and he's like
what'd you pay for that
and i told him and he just spit
and he's out of disgust yeah he said a
truck over there didn't cost that and
i'm like no that truck over there costs
200 bucks you know
and it's not a it's not a fine european
automobile
you know so i drove off all
uh
bothered that my grandpa was not
impressed with my proud new purchase
and uh of course when he passed away he
had a million dollars in money markets
um and so and the reason he did was is
he didn't put it all in things he goes i
said well this is a great car so these
things hold their value and he started
laughing and he goes ain't nothing holds
his valuable wheels on it boy
i said what do you mean he goes well it
holds its value he goes he goes so it's
like an investment he goes my
investments go up
yours go down there's a problem with
this formula using the sun did you go to
college or what you know it's that kind
of thing right one of these are these
conversations with your grandpa right
nothing like that he just whipped my
butt man oh my gosh
wow too much too much
this is the ramsey shower
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
joys in cleveland ohio hi joy how are
you
good how are you thank you so much for
taking my calls today sure what's up
um
okay i'm 46 years old and about a year
and a half ago my husband committed
suicide so
um i have had it kind of tough you know
last year and a half yeah i think um
but
yeah and then
and the whole process of it all you know
he
was
we had gotten into the rental house
business and we had you know we had
acquired i think it was 15 properties at
the time
and
several of them were fixer-uppers so
um we were kind of like in a mess so
when he passed away i i sold all of them
but ten i kept ten you know to manage
myself and
five of them are paid off and the other
five have you know small mortgages i
think the total i o on all five is 275
000
but every month they bring in um ten
thousand dollars and five thousand goes
to the mortgage payment
so you know i clear five
and um my question was
do i sell a couple now that the market
is up and just pay off my house or do i
continue to manage them because i only
have like seven years left before
they're all paid off
we had done 15-year loan
back you know in the day so
if i keep them and keep making the
payments for seven more years that would
be like a ten thousand a month income
secured income
or do i sell three and lower my income
to like seven thousand a month but have
my mortgage paid
is that confusing no it's not confusing
at all and i'm just heartbroken for you
i'm sorry for what you've been through
it's totally yeah
very tough
oh my god and i have two i have two boys
in college one just finished actually
and um with that money you know we've
been paying their school so they don't
have student loans so it's good you know
for that also
and
i'm also a nurse and i work
full time so
so who manages the properties you manage
them
i do yeah and i mean they we've had rent
i've had well now it's interesting i've
had renters
in these houses you know for years and i
think it's because i really haven't
raised the rent on them they've been
there faithfully paying and
um
you know i know i should be charging
more but i think it's almost better to
have a renter in there that good and
long term then having to keep you know
going in there painting it freshening it
up and trying to find another good
renter
you know to rent them out again so i
just pretty much keep the rents lower
and
i mean they've been there for years
these people so
what's left on your primary mortgage
well i had to leave the house we were
living in because it happened you know
in my last house so
i bought a house and i currently owe 460
000 on it
my rate is at 4
um
and the houses make the payment for me
you know i the payment is like 2 600 a
month and the rent the rent pays for
that for me so i mean whether i sell the
houses and pay off my mortgage or just
sit here
someone else is paying for it you know
so i don't know whether to just wipe it
out with if i sold three that would
probably be enough to pay it off
or do i just
let the runners continue making my house
payment and then in seven years i would
have more of a
bigger monthly payment monthly income
than if i sold three now
yeah
well um you're
making the decision
if i were in your shoes
i would be making the decision in a
weakened
state
because of what you've been through in
the last year and a half
you lose your husband in the house you
have to move out of the house because
you can't walk in there without memories
flooding
and
so you have to move you have to go
through the loss of your husband a
funeral you have to go through the
surprise the shock
everything associated with suicide
um
even some people deal with embarrassment
as if you had anything to do with it and
you didn't but that sometimes comes up
that kind of thing and you're dealing
with all of that and
then you throw in just a rental property
question
okay
rental property is a
wonderful investment i've got a bunch of
it as you know
and um uh
it is not
to be managed from weakness
and um so when you say things like oh
the renters are paying my payments
no that's not true
uh just try waiting till they don't pay
your payments and then you don't have to
pay your payments and so then you'll
know that that's not true so that's you
know if they pay the rent that's true
and you say things like i don't want to
get market rent because i might lose my
renter and so now your renter is holding
the landlord hostage no i'm going to
raise my rents every year
every time the lease is up i'm going to
raise the rents it's going to be close
to approaching market rent
and
i don't want somebody sitting there on a
10 year old rent rate
and rents have doubled during that time
and then we've got an emotional problem
when i do finally try to raise it
because i feel strong enough to do that
emotionally
and then they jettison on me i'd rather
just have some normal turnovers part of
owning rental properties if you can deal
with normal turnover and market rates
that's an indication you're in a
position of emotional strength as a
landlord to work with these things and
you want to ride them out i'm okay with
that not okay with your current plan
because of because it indicates you
listen i've had enough crap in my life
don't rock the boat is what you told me
six different ways in your conversation
i don't wanna do anything cause any
disturbance in the force i've had enough
disturbance
and i don't blame you by the way i think
that's where that that's where most
people would be that are human beings
and so i i think that so
i if i were you i'd ask myself the
question if my house was paid for and i
owned
uh the five paid for rentals
or six paid for rentals or whatever
would i go buy some other rentals
okay home payments
and i think the answer is no
so i'm going to have a smaller more
efficient
portfolio
meaning a smaller portfolio of rentals
that that are paying me market
rather than a larger portion that are
not paying me market because i don't
want to deal with a hassle
and i don't have any debt house or
anything and that's where i would want
to be and from there if you want to buy
some other rentals as the years go on
and you continue this desire to grow the
real estate portfolio and you want to do
it with cash then i would actually
absolutely go that way yeah i'm looking
down at the numbers here and there's
three quarters of a million dollars in
debt and after being what she's been
through i just want some financial peace
in my life and i want some stability and
to me i'm going i'm going to sell a few
i'm going to get rid of my mortgage it's
a lot off the shoulders a lot less to
manage in the portfolio and if you raise
the rent you might make some of that up
on the other properties so i feel good
about that plan
give yourself permission to
not be the strongest you've ever been in
your life right now
because that would just mean you're a
human
because humans hurt when they go through
things like you've been through honey
and so it's okay to just sit where you
are for a little while longer you don't
have to make any decisions there's
nothing pushing any of this and it's
okay to simplify your life
uh but at the end of the story whenever
the end is whether that at the the next
chapter of the story
whatever that is i want you to be uh
three years from now running an
efficient paid for
set of rentals
that are being charged market rate and
you're landlording from
not only financial strength but from
emotional strength
um
but no i i
um
if you're not having some turnover your
rents aren't right
that's part of the rule
and again we've got a bunch of property
and um
you know rental rates have changed a lot
last 12 months in our area they've gone
way up
and so we're seeing some pretty
substantial increases on some of our
existing tenants
and by the way if they were to leave
because we increased it guess where they
have to go rent somewhere else that's
charging market rent too
and so that they you know
that's where that's how it works out
here in the world it's this sorry
um and
so i'm not gonna not gonna lose them if
they go shopping
because i'm not over charging i'm just
charging the market that's all
and that's just efficient management of
the asset that's called good stewardship
[Music]
this is a ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
they're here kevin and ronda are with us
t-shirts say weird people that's always
a good sign yes it is i like hanging out
with weird people normal sucks out there
i don't be normal
hey guys welcome where do you all live
indianapolis ah welcome to nashville all
the way here to do a debt-free scream
how much did you pay off
uh 135 thousand six hundred dollars love
it and how long did this take uh 36
months yeah and your range of income
during that time um 160 to 180 000. cool
what do y'all do for a living i'm a
police officer
i'm an emt and i drive a special needs
school bus oh wow okay so did you all
meet on an emt police officer call i
wish
i just had this thing happening in my
head there i just said it's a very
romantic story as an ambulance and a
policeman and everything's bad except
they meet yeah so but anyway it didn't
work out that way okay so what kind of
debt was your 136 000 um we had two
iphones
and two vehicles in our house paid off
paid off the house that's the weird
people t-shirts i like it what's this
house worth uh 300 000. yay
way to go thank you how's it feel to
have no payments in the whole world it
was good the grass was definitely
different when we walked on it barefoot
about everything is different very very
cool
congratulations so what started this
journey 36 months ago well i'm 51 now
i'm an avid long distance backpacker
i wanted to retire at 57 in order to be
able to try to
hike all the long trails here in the
united states wow and
i had been investing or we had been
investing uh my entire adult life but
honestly i had no clue what i was doing
um
we traveled a lot spent a lot of money
bought a bunch of crap we didn't really
need
and we were the guys like george's uh
podcast that thought we were smarter
than the credit card company and never
paid an interest
on the credit cards but every month we
got a bill for some reason i don't
remember what we bought
um but you got points
oh yeah
yeah tell me about it um
then
looking around for smart investing we
discovered you on youtube and it was
game on from there um
i worked a lot of extra being a cop you
can basically work 24 7 if you want
my department um gives financial peace
type class so i attended that
rhonda has a side business and she
started up making crafts and gnomes
which exploded
and did really awesome
and then when we're about three thousand
dollars from getting the house paid off
um september the 26th on the way to
church well i had i had two strokes one
on the 25th uh and then one on the 26th
on the way to church and
spent a week in the hospital and you
know thank the lord that
we discovered you and for your ministry
because
you know if something happened to me and
i died or been to the point where i
couldn't function anymore um it could
have been pretty scary financially for
rhonda
and then a week after i got out of the
hospital we paid off the house just like
that wow yeah boom boom boom boom boom
yep yep
cool very good i love it quite the
journey there so that was this health
scare the thing that made you go never
again we've gotta we've to stop playing
this game no no we were already on we
were almost done with everything we only
had 3 000 left on the house and then
i stroked out that's wild that didn't
set you guys back at all you just you
just got up from that one all right
we're going to keep going
slowly
and you're doing great now
pretty much i still my artery still
completely blocked but good lord still
got me here wow
oh man
scary stuff yeah but the good news is
you're completely free as far as the
debt part goes and now
now uh all you got to deal with is a
medical yep okay
cool are they going to do something for
the blocked artery just hope it's okay i
tore it i tore it working out oh and an
idiot thinking i was 21 year old
and uh tore my carded artery working out
and there's nothing they can do if it's
fully blocked so god willing it'll heal
on its own if not
i'll deal with it okay my goodness yeah
wow wow
so do what's that due to the hiking goal
we'll see we're going out to the
appalachian trail in may and then i'm
gonna
hike 500 miles in colorado in july if
everything's going good doesn't sound
like we're changing anything i don't
know we'll see all right wow that's some
that's a lot of hiking brother beats
working
well yeah it sounds like work to me
actually but yeah yeah well
congratulations you guys what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
um first and foremost i would say having
a relationship with jesus christ
um
through our journey journey
he's been there for us and we wouldn't
be where we are today without him um we
walk with him just like your sign says
daily
and um another thing would be um focus
on your debt just stay focused on it um
i know there's going to be bad times and
good times but you just still need
just to go ahead and focus on it and
what we've done is that we've
made a little plan where we've opened
several different savings accounts
and each month we would put money in
each of those so it'd be like um fun
money
home improvement vacation car
and so um we just recently got new
cabinets for our house for our home
improvement and we're wanting to do
something else but we can't do it
unless we put that money in there and we
have it so um and just like with the fun
money um we run out that month
we don't get to go out we don't get to
do anything you know so
it's really being focused and being a
team and doing it together you know and
putting god at the center i can't
express enough how important it is to
just really focus and uh put your trust
in god amen amen
and then let's go ahead and have a
stroke that'll help you trust in god too
right oh my gosh yeah
wow yeah you realize how little control
you have when something like that
happens but the thing you can control is
getting out of debt and putting yourself
in that financial spot and correct the
way that faith and hope have intertwined
your lives and the way you guys have
held hands through this together you're
just a resilient couple there's nothing
that's going to stop them a 500 mile
hike uh a mountain of debt nothing
i hiked too so don't give him don't give
him all the credit
well you may have to carry him out on
your back i don't know he looks like he
looks like he might be a heavy load i
don't know
all right very cool so uh how much is in
investments
uh we're everyday millionaires we're
doing pretty good
i was guessing yeah 300 000 house plus
thousand
plus i have the police pension plus you
got the pension as well yeah now are you
out on disability then with that or i
went back to light duty so i uh i'd call
detectives house cats so i'm a house cat
for another month or so and then i'll be
back to the street okay all right wow
wow
i have not heard that one that's good
very good well congratulations you guys
thank you sir is it worth the journey oh
my goodness it's it was great how long
you guys been married nine years nine
years you ever been debt-free while you
were married no no until now yeah i'm
proud of you thank you very well done
your heroes thank you great job well
we've got a copy of the book every day
or the book
everyday millionaires well the baby
steps millionaires we'll give you one of
each why not yeah and uh uh get that
taken care of for you and of course a
copy of the book the total money
makeover for you to give away uh the
baby steps millionaire's book comes out
next week but we're gonna get you one
today because we know a guy can i tell
you something real quick
um
you know you've seen it from our like
giving advice um what was you saying
about being in the airplane and oh yeah
so this is kind of our it's okay
it was a joke but we'll just go on
[Laughter]
it was funny so we'll do it off air okay
we'll talk to you at the break
you can hit the punch line that way all
right good stuff guys way to go all
right kevin and ronda indianapolis
indiana 136
000 paid off in 36 months making 160 to
180 uh just in time to hike the
appalachian trail and um everyday
millionaires baby steps millionaires in
the process
very very well done you guys thank you
all right house and everything baby
they're weird people count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two
love it
well done you guys very well done
man that's fun doesn't get much better
hike the apple i call the long trails
i'm not doing it dave i'll let that i
like kevin handle that one you think
well yeah
let ronda handle it yes
she does it too yeah
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five a few
weeks ago we announced we're having a
huge event coming up next week on
thursday january the 13th it is
completely sold out for in-person
tickets
over a thousand almost 1500 people are
coming to our event and thousands more
have registered for the free
live stream if you haven't heard me talk
about it yet george campbell to my right
rachel cruz and i are going to be
talking about how to build wealth in
2022. we're going to talk about the
latest and greatest get rich quick ideas
from crypto to nothing down real estate
to single stocks nfts we're going to
show you how to do it the right way
we're going to show you how to
become wealthy the quickest and surest
way the countdown for our building
wealth event is officially begun join us
next week at this free one night only
event thursday january 13th building
wealth in 2022 don't miss the
opportunity to make sure you're on the
right track to build wealth
join the thousands who have already
registered for the free live stream
again it is sold out so we're making the
live stream available to you for free
uh you go to ramseysolutions.com
wealth to register today gonna be fun
totally free i'm still impressed gonna
be fun no reason not to be there well
george and rachel the material that they
put together and the
the team and i have put together it's
all
um i i think uh
i mean no matter what you paid for it i
think you would have gotten a return on
your investment for your wealth no pun
intended there yeah
yeah but i mean it's it i'm excited
about this me too and it feels very
fresh it's very relevant it's all
trending things that you're having
conversations about at the dinner table
with your friends and we want to just
address it head on and of course it
points back to our principles and the
fact that they do in fact work
so i'm excited to talk about it ramsay
solutions.com
wealth
one week from thursday january the 13th
you do have to pre-register but the live
stream is free
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time
always use the magic word ramsey to get
the best deal this is a great company if
you're going to put in window blinds or
window coverings blinds.com today's
question comes from dan in washington dc
i'm a landlord who owns multiple rental
properties over the past year or two
rent prices have seen a big increase
this is great for a landlord but not so
great for the tenant i know i need to
raise my rental rates to keep up with
the increased overhead costs however
this causes direct hardship to my
tenants that have been good tenants for
the past few years as a christian this
is hard for me i would feel bad if
raising rent caused them to have to move
after they've made the house their home
i did not get into real estate to
subsidize people's living expenses but i
also didn't get into real estate to
displace families either i love
investing in real estate so i don't see
myself exiting this field so i'd like to
hear your advice on how to balance this
equation
it is
sweet
that
you've got a big heart like this
and that's a nice thing and you're not
exiting the landlord field
and so you are going to have to learn to
balance your faith
uh with business practices
that are not dishonoring to your faith
um
treat other people
like you would want to be treated
okay
i lease a
building
for
ramsey solutions
that is an office warehouse we're not
the owner of it uh about five miles from
where we sit right now from our
buildings that we own
and uh the uh
lease is coming up for renewal
if the guy raises my rent to market
rate
why does that make him a bad christian
that was a passive aggressive question
the answer is it doesn't
okay i own
rental property single-family homes uh
among many other properties that we own
and if i raise my rent to
be market rate
um that does not make me a bad christian
uh i did not displace the person out of
that house if they can no longer afford
it the marketplace did
the economy did
the ratio of the income that they earned
to their housing expense displaced them
i didn't cause
any of that
and so you are not displacing them
you're taking too much credit for
what's going on
if they need to move to a cheaper house
because they can't afford they're going
to move to a lesser house
because if they move they're going to
pay market
rent
now
having said all of that i've had
situations because i manage the
properties with a heart and a head both
i don't personally manage them but we do
my family does
that if someone is
sick um
i'll just you know i remember one time a
long time ago a lady had cancer
am i going to evict someone in the
middle of chemo
no
not i'm going to work with them i'm
going to be kind i'm going to have clear
conversations i want to know what's
really going on
i don't want to be
duped by the situation but on the other
hand i also want to be treat other
people like i'd want to be treated
that's a biblical mandate
and so if i were in that situation how
would i want to be treated well i'd love
some mercy some grace
but mercy and grace because rents went
up in general
and i can't afford to live here anymore
because my job didn't go up as much as
the mark as much as the cost of a loaf
of bread or gallon of gasoline went up
because welcome to inflation
um this is not something you caused now
you can cause the cancer either but that
is a temporary thing this other thing's
going to be there forever
that family is never going to be able to
afford to live there if they can't
afford to live there
it's not going to change now if they
come in and go i'm getting a raise in
four months and here's the contract can
you wait then yeah i'll give them a
little mercy you see what i'm saying
yeah but this idea that you have to
equate christian
and kindness
with uh
not having good marketplace experience
is not true that's a that's a that's a
it's not a factual way of viewing this
and you brought this up with a caller
earlier who was kind of experiencing a
similar situation and you said hey this
is being a good steward of the the asset
that you are managing and uh you know he
says in the question that they've made
their hou the house their home it's not
their home it's your home it'll never be
their home as long as they're renting it
good point and when you're a renter you
kind of know that yeah i've been a
renter and i i didn't expect to stay
there
i'm passing through you know no one that
rents very few people that rent go i
want to be here 50 years i think i'm
just going to stay in your house for 50
years
you know no one does that this is my
forever home i'm a renter no one says
this
and honestly people don't say you know i
like taking it situation by situation
and going is this a true hardship or
is it really you've got to tighten up
the budget and so at that point i may
give them some resources maybe some
ramsey resources say hey here's the
total money makeover i want to help you
create that margin i'd love to keep you
as a tenant you've been great
and how you interact with them in
kindness is fine too you don't have to
be unkind you don't have to be cold and
transactional you can go i understand it
hurts my heart
but i'm doing this with all these things
now if you've got a property that's gone
way up maybe you stage it up
and that's how you'd want to be treated
if you were there treat other people
like you won't be treated but if you
really would expect to get to live there
on rental rates that are 75 percent of
the market forever just because your
landlord's a christian then you've got
something screwed in your brain
you really do that's just not how it's
not that is not a calling of the bible
that is not something scripture calls us
to
to under charge because we're christians
now we don't need to overcharge we don't
need to rip people off we certainly want
to tell the truth
and those kinds of things we're not
trying to take advantage in some way
but sometimes people get in their head
that anybody that sells anything can't
be a christian
you know i can't believe you don't just
give all your stuff away ramsay
all these people that work here 1100 of
them that want payroll they require that
i don't give my stuff away because they
like for their payroll checks to clear
that's how this stuff works that's why
we sell a book instead of giving away a
book
um can i personally afford to give you a
two dollar or ten dollar twenty dollar
book yeah i can personally afford to do
that but i gotta make sure that the
people here eat that work on this stuff
and so it's not an unchristian act to
have interaction in the marketplace it's
a good word all right good question i
like that dan thank you for writing that
in that's very very good
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us george campbell ramsey
personality host of the podcast the fine
print is my co-host today as we answer
your questions about your life your
money your work your relationships it's
the ramsey show thanks for being here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five
george i hadn't planned to do this but
it just occurred to me that i probably
should
say because i think our fans our super
fans that are dialed in
may have noticed that we didn't say
we're broadcasting live from the dollar
car rental studios we were missing a
little piece of the sentence there it
felt weird little piece but we're saying
it i don't know if anybody's ears caught
it or not but um so dollar car rental
had sponsored our studio for two years
and uh wonderful relationship wonderful
people and we appreciated their
sponsorship we still appreciate their
sponsorship uh when covet hit a lot of
the rental car companies went through
bankruptcy
hertz owns dollars dollar and they were
no exception and the entire marketing
team that we were working with when we
did the original sponsorship deal uh
exited during the bankruptcy and so in
the second year of working with dollar
working with a whole different group of
people which is not bad they weren't bad
people they were fine no issues at all
but the the reason we did the dollar car
sponsorship was not to get money for the
studio although we took the money
uh that's part of the deal
uh but the reason was was that we were
really really excited to have a rental
car company that would accept debit
cards and not treat debit card holders
like second-class citizens when you go
to a rental car counter
because most of them do treat you that
way and the new leadership team at
dollar reverted back to the old uh
way that most most the old policies most
the old policies that most rental car
companies use so no hard feelings there
but uh is inappropriate for us to
continue to send you guys to dollar
uh because we tell you i only have a
debit card not have a credit card and
then they uh you know they've got
standard debit card processes which are
unwieldy as far as i'm concerned and so
um you know we just we had a great run
with them for a couple of years there
and uh for a little while we got you
guys a really good situation with dollar
to be able to use your debit card and
they've gone back to normal hertz and
whatever other brand you want to throw
out there uses they all pretty much
treat debit card holders like second
class citizens kind of a normal thing
for them and it's it they're and you
know so
no hard feelings they were we're not mad
at dollar they're not mad at us just the
sponsorship came to a close because they
felt like that we didn't feel like they
should renew because it's not going to
give them value for us to endorse them
when uh we're sending people over there
who get pissed off then when they go
over there because you go in there and
go ramsey sent me over here and you
treat me like this you know so we can't
we just can't do that so
um
but it was a good run for a while and so
we're actively seeking you may hear
another
uh studio sponsor at some point might be
a rental car county might be someone
else you never know team is working on
that now but that's what happened and uh
uh not all uh relationships on things
like that end well but this one did it
was uh good people and break it's just
uh
you know they get to they get to run
their company we get to run our company
and that's how that works and it's all
good so that's why it's not there in
case you're wondering i won't cover it
again i'm not going to cover it every
day it's just something there but uh
they gave us a lot of money for two
years now we appreciated them and uh
they took care of our people for
a portion of that two years beautifully
uh and then reverted back to the old
systems and so
there we are now sidebar nothing to do
with dollar but partially to a dollar
it's just interesting we need to do this
in the fine print so you know why these
companies as we've dug into it because
we've talked to several different rental
car companies about this because trying
to get them to care not treat debit card
users like second-class citizens
apparently people there's a uh
like a mafia ring or a cartel ring
of thieves that rent
cars
and steal them
no kidding that's not shocking to me
uh but somewhere they figured out that
like .005
more of them are with like a minuscule
amount are with debit cards so somewhere
someone in the corporate jungle decided
that that this debit card usage was
associated with these massive thefts
that they really are enduring they
really have massive thefts on these
things
and so um
so they just said we'd rather not have
debit cards users and that's why they
treat them that way treat us that way so
uh
it's but it's all associated with a
misnomer i'll tell you another one
here's another one here's another
statistical misnomer okay the university
of pennsylvania in conjunction with the
university of texas did a study
oh man
25 years ago
where they found people with low credit
scores
have a higher likelihood of turning in
an automobile claim
in a wreck
and people with high credit scores have
a higher likelihood of just paying the
automobile claim
and consequently they said anybody
without a high credit score we're going
to raise your a bunch of the auto
insurance companies adopted this state
farm was the first one nationwide was
the second one adopted this idea that if
you don't have a high credit score we're
going to charge you more surcharge
of course the study did not
accurately reveal reality which is the
people that have no credit score
like
multi
millionaires like me
never turn in an auto claim unless it's
extreme
we just pay them we'll think about it i
don't turn in a two thousand dollar
claim
the building i'm sitting in is worth 400
million dollars i don't turn in a two
thousand dollar claim okay i'm not being
snotty or anything but these are just
your realities so people that are
wealthy and have a zero credit score are
not taken into account in this remote
study from 25 years ago
and then as a result everyone is thrown
out just like with a debit card user at
the rental car company everyone's thrown
out because corporate america doesn't
bother to actually understand the
details of the study well i think it's
laziness they're just wanting to lump
everyone into one camp high credit score
and then low and no score debit card
credit cards yeah cartels all use debit
cards apparently give me a break hey
they're moving at the speed of cash at
least
that's that's one good thing
that's so strange but i'll tell you this
dave i just rented a car a few weeks ago
went to arizona and we went through
enterprise i booked it through costco
travel and i had no issue using a debit
card and here's what they said at the
counter hey we're going to charge an
extra 20 hold it'll come back to you
when you return the car because of the
debit card i said okay
that was it that's no different than a
hotel exactly put a hold on your room
but the idea that people go dave oh my
my life's going to be so difficult if i
have to use a debit card it's impossible
you can't rent a car you can't do i
didn't realize i didn't realize
enterprise was that lenient that's good
maybe we need to get them to
only good experiences with enterprise
and uh you know i don't know about the
other ones that's just the one that
happened to be the best price when i
went to look but uh it can be done you
just gotta look at the policies
beforehand make sure you budget for
those kinds why did you not use our
sponsor well this was just this was just
a few weeks ago
you knew everything was coming to an end
well everything honestly it was booked
up all the rental cars oh this is you
know back when it was the rental cars
were a little up in the air if you were
not a little up in there they're a lot
up in there and so i just went with one
that was available that had the best
price all right i'll put you on the spot
here but thank you we need to make sure
we take care of our sponsors absolutely
there you go all right thanks for
clearing the air on that one well i
appreciate you cleared enterprise so
they got a free ad out of this it's good
for them
and uh so everybody although everybody's
running over to enterprise now because
of george campbell hey you're welcome
george you need to work with the guys
and help them be the sponsorship now you
got to you got to own up to them tell
them george from ramsay sent you that's
it they they know you well
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
makes it simple to shop top quality
blinds shades and interior shutters from
home with easy online ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
every january we get hundreds if not
thousands of calls from people who are
ready to start
fresh
ready to finally take control of their
money
but without a plan most of them never
make progress they give up
maybe you've been there too 2022 can be
different this year you can win with
money
by following the plan that has worked
for millions of people it's called
financial peace university that's where
we'll teach you every detail about the
blend
yup you'll learn step by step how to
save money pay off debt fast bill wealth
and give generously you can go through
the class with other people or watch it
online at home either way financial
peace university is available when you
get your ramsey plus membership and you
can watch as many times you want on at
your convenience you can join a class
you can do it all online however you
want
get control of your money and you can
actually start with a free trial at
ramseysolutions.com fpu
start financial peace university with a
free trial
ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu heather is with us heather is in
winston-salem north carolina hi heather
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave i'm so excited to talk to you
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
um yes so my husband and i are currently
in baby step six and
we
need to do some home renovations
um and i'm just not really sure if we
need to pause the baby steps to pile up
cash or if we can continue with our baby
step journey while we're piling up cash
um so i've tried to kind of find this
answer on your website and just through
other clips and things like that on
youtube and the only thing i can seem to
find is baby step 3b where people are
saving up for a down payment on their
home yeah um
so i just i kind of just wanted some
advice from you because i don't want to
mess anything up sure so how much are
these home renovations going to cost
um so we are anticipating we had some
quotes come in pre-covered and we didn't
feel good um kind of moving forward
pre-covered because it was literally
when the world was shutting down so we
got a little scared
um and then
of course hindsight being what it is had
we known that you know building costs
and things of that nature were going to
go up like they have we would have
totally pulled the trigger um
back in you know may of 2020 but um
needless to say we're figuring around um
right now quotes and things are coming
in at around forty thousand dollars
um and and what it is what's your
household income
yeah it's um it's around 145 000 a year
okay so while you're doing baby steps
four five and six you're doing them
simultaneously do you have kids you're
saving for college
um
we do we have a set of twins who are
four okay how much are you putting away
for their college
um so
not a lot right now and so are you
putting your fifteen percent away and
maybe step four for retirement
yes absolutely okay so when you save up
the 40 000 it will effectively just
lower how much you're paying down your
mortgage for a little while right
that is correct yes sir that's where you
would do it
okay so just continue with the baby
steps like we currently are and just
when we're doing the monthly budget just
slows baby step six because we're gonna
steal forty thousand dollars from that
what would have gone to paying off the
mortgage which is fine you're i mean if
you're gonna save up and buy a car same
thing if you're gonna save them by a
couch or a vacation same thing anything
you consume beyond 15 of your income
going into retirement beyond your kids
college savings
is gonna slow down your baby step six
mathematically does that make sense
yeah it does it's just my nerd brain is
really struggling with how long you know
that's going to take and i don't know
why it feels like it how much are you
paying extra on your mortgage
um we typically have about an extra 1500
to 2 000 a month that we can save let's
call that twenty four thousand dollars a
year how long does it take to get forty
thousand eighteen months yeah like a
year and a half yeah i help your nerd
brain
yeah it does it just you know i just
needed to hear you say it i
guess know so here let me ask you this
can you break the uh what i would do if
i'm in your shoes is i would break the
renovations into about two or three
phases
so let me tell you what the renovations
are um so we live in a i we live in a
small home um it's roughly 1100 square
feet we bought it as a starter home back
in 2010
um we planned on having a baby in 2017
and ended up with two babies
um so the twins are currently sharing a
bedroom so i we're adding um just some
square footage so that the twins can
actually have their own bedroom so it's
not anything extra what's your home
worth
um about 165 000. what are the homes in
your neighborhood sell for
um
it depends
um
do they sell for over 200
um
for a home similar to yours not not this
size no no i mean is there homes in if i
drive down your street am i looking for
a 200 000 house no
no
move
don't renovate you're about to overbuild
the neighborhood
i don't know well
no
okay no
no so even even if we only owe seventy
thousand dollars i don't care what you
owe that's not part of the equation
the equation is you're gonna spend forty
thousand dollars and you're gonna have
effectively a hundred two hundred five
thousand dollars in a home
that nobody looks for two hundred
thousand dollar homes and within three
five three to five streets of you ever
no one thinks of that neighborhood as a
200 to 250 000 neighborhood they think
of it as a 150 to 200 neighborhood and
you're about to lose this money you need
to just move you've got a dinky butt
house time to move up you make plenty of
money you're in good shape
okay
all right that's what i needed to hear
does that make sense to you
yeah it makes total sense it's just
maybe that's why i've been wallowing
with the idea and that's why we've been
having a hard time with feeling like
we're getting you know getting the money
saved yeah and so you don't even have to
do the money save then all we're gonna
do is just put you on a 15-year fix
where the payments are no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay and you
guys will have a great down payment with
your equity so find something that will
fit your your family's needs uh but
don't put 40 grand this renovation
that's not going to roi for you that's
just a bad idea good catch george
good catch okay yeah all right thank you
so much i appreciate you both thank you
darling we appreciate you calling
appreciate you letting me uh
tell you directly how it works open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five ramsay you're just
more brutal than you used to be yeah i
was just shorting to the end hey life's
short we gotta be direct yeah i gotta
get there fast jimmy's in new york city
hey jimmy what is up in your world
hey dave how you doing i'm gonna be
precise i have
seventeen thousand dollars in savings to
my name
i make fifty thousand dollars a year
uh hold on to your seat my rent is five
hundred dollars a month my debt is zero
you have a 500 a month rent in new york
city you live in a cardboard box
i live in the bronx but um it's been in
my family my father's been renting and
pass it on to
all right
so you make 50 and you have 17 saved and
you're 49 years old
yes and your questions your question's
what
my question is what can i do
to retire
at least maybe not wealthy but
comfortable
well here's the thing you've got no
money in investments right now you just
have the 17 to your name and savings
yes do you have a 401k at your job
um yes but
very little money is going in there
well you have no debt you've got it
looks like an emergency fund with that
17k maybe more than you need and so you
got to start investing at least 15
percent of your income into that 401k
maybe you open up a roth ira and you max
that out
but 15 of your income which out of 50k
is going to be what 7 500 exactly
and obviously i want you to do more than
that at 49 if you're hoping to retire in
the next you know 15 20 years but once
you've got are you looking to have a
paid for house one day or are you going
to keep running
uh i my goal is to have a house one day
but
that's that's my real goal to have a
house yeah yeah do you have a roth 401k
available at work
yeah i believe so yeah okay start
talking to them about the options there
if you've got good mutual fund options
to start that i'm with george let's put
15 percent of your income 7 500 let's
call it 9 000 even we round up a little
here
into that uh per year
and if you do that especially if they
match you're going to be okay when you
get to retirement in 10 years or so or
10 or 15 or 20 years rather this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the dead free stage mike and sierra
are with us hey guys how are you doing
great dave how are you i am better than
i deserve happy new year how much debt
did you guys pay off over 137 000 whoa
where do you guys live pottstown
pennsylvania which is near
an hour from philadelphia okay cool how
long take you to pay off the 137 30
months
good
and your range of income during that
time 125 to 148.
cool what do you guys do for a living
i do digital media marketing and i'm an
esl teacher oh very good very good good
stuff all right fun so what kind of debt
was your
137 thousand dollars well
the big one was student loan debt uh we
had a couple of cars in there we had uh
some electronics we had a
personal loan uh but the big one was
really the student loans yeah how much
did your own student loans
yeah it was at one point it was well
over a hundred thousand okay wow yep he
still looks kind of heavy when he said
at one point it was just infected yeah
he still feels it it was really heavy
yes
it was gone but it's gone now i love it
it's gone yeah so very very cool very
cool so what are you guys 28
i'm 30 31 almost like i've done this
before good okay yeah that's about where
you should be except now you're debt
free
what happened two and a half years ago
you rocked this
um so i know for me i'm having our first
daughter that sort of spearheaded it and
then in the beginning um we
were sort of ish and then it really like
i wanted to eventually be able to stay
home on a maternity leave with the girls
at some point and
yeah i mean
you know we just weren't really working
as a unit so
um it was kind of like oh well uh you
know you take care of all the house
stuff mike and i'll take care of all
these bills over here and we weren't
really working as one
so that was like what sparked the
conversation what was it we got to do
something and then the ramsey name pops
up
well we were in between two churches at
the time and one of the churches that we
attended was hosting um
and so then we decided to
join that and we had had our first
daughter
and we were
you know really paycheck to paycheck
because we were just covering everything
at the house and just covering the basic
um debt payments and we were like this
is going to go on forever if we continue
this way no oh my god so so you have the
daughter and you go these student loans
are killing us that's debt is killing us
there's got to be another way let's try
this ramsay thing and see how it works
yep and it worked yes yes it did so
financial peace university you're in the
class you were really ready so you're
going to class the first night uh how
long did it take before you thought i
think i might be able to do this
hmm well i mean for a while because we
were first digging out it seemed
like it was going to take a while i
think for us what happened was uh we
ended up having our second and so we had
kind of had to push pause on everything
for a little bit and it was kind of you
know after uh sierra came home everybody
was healthy
and we kind of took a look at the
numbers and we said okay you know
let's let's push play let's do this now
we gotta go game on ready set boom yep
come out of the blocks hard then yeah we
said uh we got it we got to get it done
before we have another one and we
actually have another one coming
you made it we made it all right
party on so cool what made you guys go
you know what we're not going to wait on
student loan forgiveness because most
people are your age they're thinking
that they're going well i don't want to
pay it off i mean they're paused and
student unforgiveness might happen what
made you guys go no we're going to take
control so i know um
most of the student loans were from mine
and just hearing other stories about how
student loan forgiveness didn't always
work the way that it that it was said to
work
we didn't want to chance anything so we
were like we want to get this done we
want to get this over with we don't want
to have to
continue with payments as the girls get
older we want to be able to be free
spend time with them
take them on vacations you know do
things with them saving for their
college so that they didn't have to go
through having quite so much debt like i
did um
that really
speared it we wanted to get it done fast
as soon as fast as we could
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of details
uh well i think the big thing is working
together focusing in on your budget
really honing in and just remembering
that the budget isn't
uh it isn't your enemy even though you
might think it is you know it's it's the
permission to spend your money where it
needs to be spent yeah and i think also
we're doing the work i know both of us
like i worked two jobs while i was
pregnant he worked multiple
multiple jobs so we both took on extra
jobs to increase our finances but we had
to find a way that fit for us so when i
was working two
um that didn't really quite work because
then i you know we had our second and i
sort of needed to be with the girls more
than so then that's when he took on the
second so we sort of balanced it out by
working together yeah
and i think just uh you know
working with your side hustles you just
got to find the right formula and you
know we ended up finding the right
formula for us and
it also helped that they put pause on
the the interest on the students yeah
that helped that accelerated it for you
so what was your most lucrative side
hustle
uh probably
uh the dominance i was delivering
dominoes from about four nights a week
what were you making a night or four
four night week what would you make four
night week uh at least like 400 bucks
sometimes 500 in the beginning um
so
it started you know during the pandemic
we had we had ensley
uh she came three weeks early um and
then on her due date literally
everything shut down
um and then
you know kind of when we were sitting
and then we we um
when we decided to get pizza and i'd
been listening to the podcast a lot and
for some reason i just kept hearing
deliver the pizzas deliver the pizzas
and
i i said okay let's let's do this and i
started delivering pizzas four nights a
week wow so
yep that's a lot of sacrifice with
babies at home littles at home and a
pregnant wife at home and that kind of
stuff yep you feel like now when you
look back it was worth it oh absolutely
absolutely so if you had to do it again
to be free it's worth it for sure
because the freedom feeling is
everything yes
yeah and while they're little they you
know they got to spend extra time with
their grandparents and that and now we
really get to spend all that extra time
with them as they grow up and yeah they
enter school and that and the big thing
for us too was we actually finished two
weeks shy of our five-year wedding
anniversary
so it was
really cool you know we were looking at
the numbers and it was like i i think we
might be able to do this before our
anniversary
and sure enough
two weeks before we made that final
payment and they were gone i love it
that's incredible well congratulations
guys we're proud of you thank you way to
go heroes you took control of your life
it's empowering isn't it no absolutely
yes you feel powerful you feel like you
can do stuff yes you did stuff that's
where that comes from i like it very
very well done well we've got a copy of
the new book baby steps millionaires for
you that'll be your next chapter for
sure to go on and be millionaires let's
bring the kiddos in what are their names
and ages zara's four and ensley is about
22 months all right very cool with the
matching dresses cute kiddos
i love it very well done good stuff all
right guys way to go excellent excellent
work
mike and sierra
zara and ensley from the philadelphia
pennsylvania area 137 000 paid off in 30
months making 125 the 148. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
man love it
it's amazing what happens when you have
a big enough y and you're not afraid to
do the work
and you know i'm uh when we had this
presentation at staff meeting this
morning the team is really checking the
data points on people that win
the number of people that get out of
debt that are working extra jobs
temporarily that have temporarily
stopped their retirement investing
and that used any savings that they had
that was non-retirement any wealth that
they had that was non-retirement to get
out of debt uh down to that one thousand
dollars in other words they're working
our plan those are three key components
working our plan while you're in baby
steps one through three it increases
their probability of actually getting
out of debt and the speed at which they
get out of debt dramatically when we're
starting to collect data that is showing
this on all the hundreds of thousands of
people we work with on an ongoing basis
this is the ramsey show
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
thank you for joining us we talk about
your life your work your relationships
your money
you
it's all about you the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five matt is in kansas city hi
matt welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call hi
george as well hey sure what's up
so i've been a public school teacher for
28 years and over the last few years
i've really felt
unsettled in my current job and really
feel that our kids especially
teens including my own son need to be
better equipped in their spiritual walk
with god and so
i feel like god is calling me to start a
christian private school in our area to
better equip our kids in their faith
and so a couple questions that i have
for you is
if this is something that truly god
wants me to do
what advice do you have in getting
something set up and two is this
feasible
to get something like this started like
say
in the coming fall
well i mean basically this is how do i
start a business question
kind of yeah your motivation is not
business and profit but this is how do i
start an endeavor and i'm a school
teacher
right because it's not about teaching
right now in terms of the question
you're asking me this is about starting
and running a school
which is a business operation the
teaching is the thing that occurs after
you get everything else done agreed
yes absolutely so if you were gonna come
to entree leadership and ask me this
question uh you know what which you can
do and you can ask here on the air
i i don't know how to start a private
school i've never done it
um i've never been involved in one
personally and it sounds like neither of
you
and so we would be starting at the same
place and the first thing i'm going to
do is find as many people doing a
similar thing
successfully that i want to do and i'm
going to try to go spend a day with them
if they'll let me
okay take a vacation day and
um you know if there's one in st louis
drive over there
if there's one in tacoma uh or not
tacoma i'm sorry
if there's one in oklahoma city drive
down there i'm trying to think of stuff
in your area okay or whatever i don't
care okay jeff city right i don't care
uh whatever you can find in your
immediate area who's somebody doing
something like you want to do
and go
observe listen
take a yellow pad ask 5 000 questions
how would you do it what were the things
you didn't see coming
uh one of the greatest rewards
uh how you know if you had it to do over
what would you do different
uh uh how did you do your pricing how
did you get the clients
i mean how did you get the first
students the parents that paid you
i'm aware vaguely
of some small
micro schools
that are a handful of kids
you know 50 kids and that kind of thing
that are uh right that are taught
classically and they're taught
uh with a christian perspective and with
a similar motivation to what's driving
you to do this
uh and so you're you know it's not like
you have to open something with 500 kids
the first year are you going to do that
by fall the answer is no
you're not right yeah we were kind of
kind of thinking that if we could start
with you know 20 or 30 kids and maybe do
like a few grades like middle school and
high school yeah how are you going to
get your curriculum what curriculum are
you going to offer
how you get your certifications that are
necessary with the state
what benchmarks are necessary with the
state to make you continue to make you
legal what what guidelines have they got
to meet if they guys testing at your
state level uh to to you know maintain
your search uh and
i'm making every bit of this up right
sitting right here i have no idea what
i'm doing but i've got to go figure all
that out
because it's not about what you teach in
the classroom and it's not about your
spiritual calling
those two things are a given well you're
an expert on those things you won't be a
debt you won't have a deficit on those
where you will have deficit is in how to
run and start this business because you
don't know squat about it and i don't
either
george have you ever done this not quite
but i i just keep going back to two
things start small and do it with cash
and that may not be this fall but there
are you know you got to start dreaming
about what do i want this to be am i
okay with this being 20 kids for now and
if so i need to start gathering interest
are there people in my neighborhood in a
local facebook group who would be
interested in sending their kid to this
and how much are they willing to pay and
so find out what the going rate would be
can you sustain an income off of that i
would write down all of these questions
and do all the research meet with all
the people and start to get some answers
on this and move forward yeah you got to
build a business model from facts and
what we're doing when we study these
other existing schools is studying what
we call best practices
okay in business if i want to learn how
to do uh a uh a digital offering of
whatever i i do a podcast i go talk to
people that are doing successful
podcasts i visit them i ask how they're
doing their podcast they ask them how to
do their marketing what length they're
doing what what they're charging for
their ads uh how much viewership or
listenership they've got um you know i'm
gonna learn everything i can about it
from some people that are successful
already doing it and then i come back
and start my podcast i don't just wake
up one morning and say now i are a
podcaster there are people that do that
but that's not the proper way to start
and run a new idea
right do you think you would have to set
up like as a 501c3
as a non-profit once you kind of got
your ducks in a row do you think that
would be the route to go
i have done that and that takes about
six months maybe longer in the covent
environment
because the irs uh not like they ever
worked a lot anyway but now they really
don't work so um
uh everything's running slow
and uh so you know you
and if so if you're gonna have the
if you're gonna have outside donations
other than tuition paid for
services given if you've got tuition
paid for services given you don't have
to have 501c3 for that
gotcha okay but outside donations that
are tax deductible the tuition is not
tax deductible at a christian school
because you're buying tuition
it's not it's not a donation it's not a
charitable donation you're buying
something there's goods and services
offered for money and that's so the
parents you don't need it for a tax
deduction that's the only thing 50501c3
gives you is the ability for the a donor
to have a tax deduction so but yeah you
need to get started on that yesterday
and that takes a while and that's not
that hard you can get touched with one
of our tax elps they can work you
through the paperwork and get that
application made i'd probably go and get
that done just make up for your name
that you want it to be you don't even
have to have the name of the school
being that but just take your best guess
at it get that rolling um but then
you've got to decide where your money's
coming from are you going to charge
enough tuition to operate the thing
yeah it would be
pretty self-sufficient i mean we would
there's a couple other families that we
kind of talked about doing this with as
well but yeah we would be able to put in
some but it would be
pretty much
you know the tuition that we would bring
in look for outside donors to support
the dream
well that's something we're going to
talk with
the people in our congregation at church
may be about and just have them pray
over it and see if maybe god's moving
them to kind of help it as well
okay
that would be cool for seed money to get
started that's not cool as your
long-term business model
if your long-term business model is
going to be raising funds from the
outside it cannot be based on one
congregation's prayers
right you need a bigger bowl that you're
fishing in than that
so you need to have a model in your mind
that we're gonna we're gonna go to other
congregations and show them the dream in
the area show them what we're doing and
ask other people to pray about it as
well and you're in the fundraising
business then as well as the school
operation business and there's nothing
wrong with that but if the if the only
way you stay open 10 years from now is
your current congregation is is propping
you up still you're probably going to
struggle maybe not make it
yeah no that makes that make sense
absolutely so it's okay for seat money
if a couple of your big guys in that
congregation want to get you out of the
boat and get you swimming that's good
i'm okay with that but you'll drown out
there if you if you just lean on one so
you decide okay 80 percent of our money
is going to be from operational tuition
and 20 is going to be from donations and
that means we need to raise x per year
and that means we need to talk to uh
however many fundraisers how many things
we're going to do to raise that money
you can get all those numbers i'm making
all that up on the spot i don't know but
you're just developing a business model
here
uh because a non-profit is a business
it is a business non-profits that don't
make a profit go out of business they
all make a profit it's just a tax and
accounting issue that's all it is
and it's no more holy or less holy than
a for-profit business either
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host george campbell ramsey
personality host of the podcast the fine
print on ramsey networks is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five as we talk about your work
your relationships your money and you
right here on the ramsey show riley
starts off this hour in sioux falls
south dakota hi riley how are you hey
dave doing well how about you better
than i deserve how can george and i help
good some quick background info here i'm
26 my wife is 24 and we have a three
month old baby yay
we i recently graduated from physical
therapy school in may and just just
started working and my wife will be
finishing up her pt school here in may
this coming may
um so we have a total we have a total of
161 000 in loans student loans all
student loans um
[Music]
and
we currently have thirty thousand on in
cash right now um but we'll have
eighteen thousand after we pay for this
next her next semester here coming up
um i'm sorry when does she graduate
this coming may 2022.
okay so that's the last semester
correct this is yep okay so that no more
expenses after you pay that 18 out of
the 30. correct okay uh 12 12 30 18 left
over yeah okay
all right
um what do you make so my biggest
uh my monthly take home is about 56
right 50 to 5600 right now
so you're making like 70 000 bucks
what's she gonna be making about the
same
yeah about that maybe a little less yeah
so 70 grand or so okay
each each yeah so about 140 000 okay
yeah and so my question is since i'm
making payments on my loans right now
do we do
my loan smallest to largest and start
knocking those out or do we just add
them all up hers included
since she's not making payments and just
do it all together smallest largest
yeah i mean this is uh our debt now
since you're married so i would just
pile them all smallest to largest and
start plowing through those and because
you're going to start to feel the
progress and you're cash flowing the
remainder of her school which is great
because you're not adding to this this
pile of debt but you guys are going to
have a great income coming out of this
and you know you take on an extra side
job you slash the budget down you're
going to get rid of this stuff real fast
when the
last payment is made on 161 000
it will not have changed the date by a
dime
due to your starting one or the other
first
that doesn't change it
so it just george is right it doesn't
you know she's out in six months you got
six more months before you have to start
paying but um you know and if you want
to set hers aside because there's no
payments on them and just start plunking
through yours first and then when hers
activate uh six months after graduation
approximately a year from now
you could add them back in at that point
and start attacking them because they're
not draining anything on you right now
with no payments being made right
correct uh her undergrad are federal so
it's obviously stopped with that and no
interest um
her and she also has private loans for
grad school which are it all ought to be
on hold though because she's still in
school
correct yep and it's all on hold until
six months after she graduates right
correct yep regardless of covet
yes sir okay so that six i mean six
months before she graduates and
six more months approximately puts us
back here at this time next year for her
start
i mean you could go either way i i may
want to go your direction just because i
like getting rid of some of the payments
that you've got
and that's what i was thinking too yeah
we weren't sure where to start so
it's okay to go either way
uh george george's point of working
together to knock out both of them is a
big deal so 100
when her payments come due the first
month you reset your debt snowball and
integrate the two over it with each
other right
perfect yep that makes total sense yeah
but if you're if you're gonna go ahead
and knock yours out first in the
meantime how many little ones have you
got can you knock out in a
year um
my my lowest balance is about
10 000 so
hopefully
i'm not sure three or four
oh wow okay so you're gonna get after it
good well and she'll start work and and
shortly after she finishes graduation
and so forth yeah yeah i'm in that'll
give you a nice raise when she starts
working and if you can get your expenses
down to nothing and you've got 11k take
home coming in you're going to knock
these student loans out really fast if
you guys get after it make sure you're
not having too much withheld too
in the process so hey good job man good
job thanks for calling in uh liz is with
us in jacksonville florida hi liz
welcome to the ramsay show
hi yes can you hear me okay sure what's
up
yes um
so i'm just trying to figure out if i
should
what i or if i should change my career
and if so
i'm kind of confused about to what um i
kind of feel like i'm short on time
to some background i am 29 years old um
i'm a teacher
and i'm on baby step two i make about
53k a year
growth and i have three kids age six
four and one
and i'm a single mom paying for both
aftercare and daycare so there's not
much wiggle room in my budget
but i wake up every morning at four and
go to bed around or excuse me and get
home around six pm so there's not a lot
of time to spend with the kids which i
feel guilty about which is one of the
reasons that i kind of want this career
shift
and i'm feeling anxious every morning
going into work just because i feel like
i'm not getting enough sleep
and things of that nature
so with all that
i know that i want a career shift i've
taken the get clear assessment but i'm
still kind of confused as to what i
should do and also
trying to figure out you know how to
manage the time to be able to do it
okay let's be clear
there's probably not a career
that makes a single mom
with four
with three kids six and under
not have a pile of stress
your your life is stressful it's just
it's it's the stage you're in
thank god it's not gonna be forever
but uh i mean raising three bet littles
on your own and working full time at
anything
is really tough
i don't think that's gonna get better
until they grow up some
okay
i mean one-year-olds and that kind of
stuff it's just you're in a really tough
situation kiddo so um
now if you've got something you can do
that makes you twice as much money on
half the time spent let's talk about it
let's do it
yeah but you know if you didn't have a
job
and you're at home full-time you have a
stressful life
yeah
right i mean it's
my grandbabies are this age i just spent
a week with seven of them you have a
stressful job
right
so do you love teaching
um i feel like it's it's not my
chosen like my career path long term for
sure you can do anything you wanted to
that's what i'm really not sure about um
i'm really not sure i you know i listen
i've been listening for about a year now
and you know i hear different people
call in and talk about that thing that
really gets them to wake up in the
morning something that they would do
even if they weren't being paid for it i
mean i love the influence
i love the ability to teach just not
necessarily academically
you know yeah you are you have a
teacher's heart it's the setting and the
life stage that's that's weighing you
down
hey hold on we're gonna hook you up with
ken coleman and his show and see if he
can walk you through and do a better job
than we were able to do for you
[Music]
you
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we are really excited next week is
the launch date for baby steps
millionaires the first book i have done
in eight years
all the other books we've done here at
ramsey have been with ramsey
personalities and actually the last book
i did was with my daughter rachel uh
cruz ramsey personality and smart money
smart kids it was a number one thank you
and this first major trade book i've
done i mean we've done some odds and end
things but i'm a major trade book this
is the first time we've done this
and so um
hey i love to have you guys pick up a
copy of baby steps millionaires how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too this is the
proof that's in the pudding baby i mean
this is how it works and uh we can prove
to you
that you can become a millionaire in
america today it's not
it's not false it's not saying you can't
fix it's not saying there's not problems
out there
it's saying you can overcome them
and you can work your way through these
things it is very very very possible for
you to pull this off
we've got the data to show you we've got
the stories to tell you
we've got 30 years of experience of
leading people and showing them to
become baby steps millionaires
and it'll prove it to your
brother-in-law who thinks that wealth
inequality requires socialism
because it doesn't
and so this is my little private war on
socialism
uh so you know you you need to know that
you're not going to convince left winger
dingers that things are different than
they are but then they think they are
but that's okay i mean just those
convinced against their wheeler have the
same opinion still you still love them
and uh you still take care of them and
uh you just like in the south we say
bless your heart right and move on so
baby steps millionaires how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth how
you can too it's a 28
book or whatever books are costing these
days we got it on sale pre-sale for just
a few more days for 20
if you pre-order the book
between now and the time we launch it
next tuesday
you're going to get 100 worth of bonus
items includes the baby steps
millionaire's audiobook read by me
and ebook the legacy journey audiobook
and ebook the baby steps millionaires
live stream which is going to be george
and rachel and i is thursday it's free
you can get that if you don't get the
book by the way
and the ramsey smart tax filing for your
federal taxes and a 30-day free trial of
ramsey plus which is rent which gets you
into financial peace university all of
that for 20 bucks for baby steps
millionaires be sure and check it out
triple eight eight two five five two
five if you want to talk we're here to
help richard is with us in los angeles
hi richard welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave hello george thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up
um i'd just like to talk to you a little
bit a side note is i just hooked up
recently with a smart vester pro after
listening to your show for a couple of
months
and we finally locked in our agreement
to work together and but right before
the holiday so now these last two weeks
i've been spinning like a top after my
wife and i finally paid off a bunch of
debt over the
quite a few years and now i just have
some uh uh questions before i get back
together with the smart vester pro in a
week or two and i just couldn't i just
couldn't uh hold myself back from
dialing and fire
well we're honored we're honored what's
up
uh you're the best um
um uh
okay so i think we're around three beers
right now so to speak the consumer debt
personal debt irs all the debts are paid
off and that was a lot of money we have
six months emergency fund locked in
we have uh our 401k going and we have a
little schwab account as well
my question is
i received this
four percent match
at work right and i believe
i'm not supposed to be
contributing anymore if i'm following
your program right um
and i just wanted to know about that and
also i don't know if we're three b-ish
because we still have i have i took a
loan we took a loan off the 401k to pay
off a personal thing that was on our
hearts they didn't want us to pay it
back they said we don't have to pay it
back blah blah blah but according to our
hearts and
our integrity
we took the loan paid back i paid about
25 we paid about 25 grand so far got
about another 25
left a little over 20 left
you have a 401k loan of 25 000
yeah left that's been uh how much is in
your schwab account
the schwab is
a little over 30. oh write a check and
pay off the 401k line
just get that out of the way yes yeah
401k loan is your own money
right you borrowed your own money so yes
you need to pay it back yeah it's part
of your baby step two actually so yeah
you need to knock that out now we have a
5 000 swab account and now we're at baby
step 3b yes so richard we we don't tell
people they have to stop 401k
contributions in 3b that's when you're
paying off your consumer debt in step
two now 3b looks different for a lot of
people you are in the los angeles area
if this is going to take you seven years
to save up a down payment i don't want
you to miss out on investing so it may
be a mix where you invest up to the
match or you invest the 15 whatever
money money's left over you throw
towards the down payment uh so you can
move forward with you know kind of the
four through six while saving a down
payment 3b is for when people want to
get intense and they can do it in under
two years they can save that down
payment they can pause investing for a
short period of time so that they can
get into that house what does that time
frame look like for you
here's the punch line uh the time frame
is fine we could i could have the down
payment we can it within a year about a
year maybe uh 14 16 months we'll see uh
but the punchline is this
i'm 57 and my wife is 54
and we're renting um we both owned homes
previously marriages and stuff like that
but we were blessed to be married
uh seven years ago the right way in in
god's uh grace and we want to continue
to do the right thing and be responsible
here
so
what do you think about that nothing is
irresponsible in our discussion here
okay so let's revisit what george is
saying because he's he's got this
exactly right
you're being very wise and you're being
very careful richard way to go i'm proud
of you
so
what i would tell you to do is number
one let's today write the check out of
the schwab account pay the 401k loan off
now you are officially at baby step
three have finished baby step three
you've got your emergency fund in place
now we start with a down payment now
baby step 3b can as george said mean a
lot of different things to a lot of
people
sometimes at baby step 3b people don't
start
baby step 4 at all
they don't start their retirement
restart their retirement
until they save their house down payment
so zero going to retirement
sometimes they put a little into
retirement
and a bunch into their down payment
sometimes people go ahead and start 15
on their 401k
and then just save their down payment
above that
which would take you a little longer
obviously
okay another question
do you think i should keep
uh enough of the four percent match we
have 270 in the 401k
and
either one's okay
there's not there's not a dumb answer
here
okay because you're going to have a down
payment saved in a year if you do
nothing towards retirement and you're
going to get retirement going full blast
after that
understood so you're not you're going to
be okay
or if you really want that match
mathematically because it scratches your
itch i'm kind of like you on that i kind
of hear that in your voice it's kind of
a math nerd thing for you you hate to
walk away from that free money
that's just means that's a little bit
less you're going to have to save
towards your down payment might take you
a month or two longer to save your down
payment right
yes and it might take you six or eight
months longer if you put the whole 15
percent in
none of those are wrong answers each of
those are just personal preference
your choice
in our plan
all of it's ultimately up to you your
adults you get to do whatever you want
to do with your money but to clarify
that's what 3b is a little bit
uh you make up your own crap there uh in
the inside the plan um
and then you we just ask that you don't
save for a house for like seven years
and not do retirement like george
specially at his age yeah exactly
especially there that'd be a bad idea
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage jake and jill are with
us hey guys how are you good you're
doing good welcome where do you guys
live uh hastings minnesota which is near
uh twin cities
okay minneapolis st paul good cool
welcome to nashville thank you and how
much debt have you guys paid off four
hundred and four thousand eight hundred
and twelve dollars
how long did this take
56 months wow and your range of income
during that time is about 125 to 215.
nice jump nice jump what do you guys do
for a living uh we run a lawn irrigation
company
wow so business got good huh yeah really
good you've been growing it fast over
the last five years trying to yeah well
done good for you guys very cool what
kind of debt was your 405 thousand
dollars well we had a whole bunch a lot
of credit cards we basically ran our
business off of credit cards we had a
home equity line of credit
we had some equipment like a tractor and
a skid loader
we had
a personal loan
and we paid off our house
like the last part a lot yeah so what is
how much of the mortgage how much
mortgage was how much of the 405 000 was
the house mortgage it was probably about
260 of it probably oh okay so almost
almost three quarters of it yeah yeah
wow okay and then just the rest of us
business stuff yeah pretty much you just
put the business on credit cards and
business owned loans and you cleaned all
of it up business is debt-free house is
debt-free we are debt free
i love it very cool it's good very cool
i love it guys okay impressed so uh what
put you guys on this journey 56 months
ago tell me the story well we had gone
on a vacation like a family vacation um
you know paradise we were gone to get
home and it was like oh my gosh if money
doesn't come in i don't know how i'm
going to make the next payment
and so it just was a huge reality check
and i
um i had we had heard about you guys at
a church that we had attended in the
past and
so i just
dug it all back out and looked into it
and i read the book
and
i started listening to all the podcasts
non-stop and
just
basically told him this is what we're
going to do
happy wife happy life you know what i
mean
you just went along with it oh
yeah exactly tried the best i could you
know
so uh jake at what point did you catch
up to all what she was doing and say all
right i understand and i'm part of it
well you know it took a little bit of
time but uh
i i seen the results as we just started
picking away at things and it just it
could see life was getting better and
better and better so well i saw your uh
obviously the income from your business
went way up during this period of time
too
what happens to a lot of people i see
with entre leadership people all the
time is
that uh as you get control of the money
and you see the actual measurable
progress
it does it with me too it motivated me
to work even more oh yeah because i felt
like i wasn't spinning my wheels for
nothing oh yeah no pun intended with you
driving a skid loader and a mowers and
everything else but yeah but i i felt
like i was getting traction it became a
game like i'll work some more let's get
it done i work some more let's get it
done right you got a goal to hit and
you're measuring it you just get after
it yeah is that part of why your income
went up oh yeah and you know every time
you got a debt paid for i mean you're
that much closer to the driver's seat
you know and it's like no nobody can
control what we got going on anymore
we're in control but i started reading a
lot of different kinds of books that you
know how to run a business i didn't go
to school for that you know i married
into that and then when we started
having kids it was just it wasn't going
to work for me to work outside the home
so he bought his business partner out
this was years ago and you know that was
how we were going to do it and i i just
i dove in you're doing all the back
office mm-hmm yeah yeah you got it and
uh and that's that the stress with that
and kids and house bills oh my god yes
if he buys another good loader you're
going to kill him exactly yeah crazy
husband you know
all right so next time you need to buy
equipment because you will you have
straight up cash that's it that's it
very good yeah i'm curious what made you
guys go not only we're gonna clean up
all this business debt the credit cards
but we're gonna pay off the house too
that's another level i knew for me it it
wasn't gonna feel done until it was all
done you know like he said raising a
family is stressful enough so
you know if that's the one thing i could
have taken off like i don't have to
worry about that anymore there's enough
to worry about all of that you know
that's all of that so you brought the
kiddos all of that how many how many
kiddos you got we have six all right
bring them up let's hear their names and
ages okay so the oldest is lydia this is
lydia she's 17.
emily is 15.
donnie is 14.
mally's 13.
um hank is seven and tom is six okay so
how many of these guys driving mowers
as many as it can get
but they can reach the pedals right you
got it yeah
i like it that's good it's good for them
absolutely these guys will turn out man
they know how to run a business they
know how to work and they their mom
knows how to run the checkbook man i'm
telling you this is pretty pretty
impressive very well done you guys all
right what do you guys tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
well you gotta you gotta work together
you know and and uh you gotta have the
same plan
so yeah for me it was
i kept i would have to dream you know it
was like i could picture what that was
gonna feel like i knew
i knew it was gonna happen but you know
when i
going through this you know all this
ramsay stuff is what made me realize
like there is hope i didn't have hope i
didn't know how to do any of it so but
then i started watching the debt free
screams and it's like oh we can do this
like this is it's going to happen yeah
yeah you guys are impressive very cool
thank you very cool you found a way and
you found a way you weren't waiting on
somebody else to fix it you scratch and
claw your way through it yeah and
there's always a book somebody's always
got a book i mean my books have saved my
life man they've taught me everything so
i'm gonna give you a copy of entree
leadership too have you read that one
yet
okay all right well you don't need to
give you one there you go
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you it comes out next week but we
got a pre
pre-launch copy for you guys to say uh
congratulations because you're going to
be baby steps millionaires if you're not
already what's the house worth
about 375 okay you might be there
already how much you got in investments
probably about
300. okay you're almost there yeah
unless you're well we count the business
assets too you are there yeah yeah all
right congratulations baby step
millionaires too right in the process
it's not that unusual we hear the house
payoff for them to make that same time
that's uh not unusual for both those
things to happen around the same time
good stuff guys
way to go also a copy total money
makeover you can give it away to some
friends stir up their life it's a good
thing to do so you guys are very very
impressive couple
hard working
and diligent scratch and claw get her
done hustle and grind good good people
thank you thank you so much we're
honored we're
you guys are why we do this very very
good stuff all right it's jake and jill
lydia emily donny mally hank and tom i
hope i got all that right in the uh
saint paul minnesota or saint paul
minneapolis area in minnesota
405 000 paid off house and everything
these are weird people they did it man
56 months making 125 all the way to 215.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one we're dead free
i love it
there's so many of them i couldn't tell
who screamed it was just it's amazing
well i'll tell you what
you know one thing about a large family
you do learn to work together there's no
other option
uh i mean we've got friends we've got
folks on our staff here that have six
eight ten kids that kind of thing and uh
you're gonna do that you've gotta learn
to work together so it's easy for them
to apply these ideas of okay what do we
gotta do let's all get together huddle
up boom let's get it done teamwork and
it makes all the difference in the world
and when you're running a small business
and you don't have any
debt
nothing on your home nothing on your
equipment nothing on anything and next
time you get ready to buy equipment the
key answer okay you're gonna pay cash
for it baby that's uh it's gonna set
them up to be unbelievably well this is
gonna take off now what's already taken
off but yeah now it's all theirs i mean
the money's all there now you get to
bring it home it's like mine now what do
i do you handle clients differently when
there's no no dead in the picture yeah
you don't put up with the crazy ones no
you don't need to yeah you fire you fire
those
and there's a few of them need firing
i'll just tell you for sure i might do
that this week
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 65 11 you
crown the year with your bounty and your
carts overflow
with abundance
thomas edison said if we did all the
things we were capable of we would
literally astound ourselves
ah that should be our that should be our
goal for 2022.
ourselves i like that
if we could just astound kelly
that is not going to happen but uh maybe
we could astound ourselves that would be
okay astound that's a great word yeah i
want to astound myself
nick is with us in dallas texas hi nick
welcome to the ramsay show hi dave hey
yeah if only we could be astounding um
so
i uh
i think i already know the answer to
this um i've read all your books and
i've i've watched the podcast and all
the things
and i i think that that last call that
the family that was just on there was
was really awesome um honestly that's
probably all i really needed because i
think i know where this call is going to
go
um so here's the situation uh i'm a new
travel nurse
i moved all the way to dallas texas from
richmond
and i ended up getting into a wreck
uh i got this 2000 toyota 4runner
and it's been my baby it's made it to
250 000 miles and
it's it's pretty much time to say
goodbye i got appraised
at 8 000
on the first appraisal and then the
second was
uh two and a half but that guy that guy
hasn't called me back and he's kind of
from a sketchy area
so
i think what i'm looking at here is
getting uh getting the beater
but i'm a little nervous because if i
did
i don't know if it'd be so safe on the
highways when i when i go to my next
place
and um
my friend
he used to be a car salesman and he's
been he's been trying to tell me that
it might just make more sense to to go
ahead and get a car loan and
get something new because of the
inflation a car salesman told you this
this is a credible piece of information
yeah
yeah
all right okay wait a minute dude have
you gained money
not no all right we've we've been best
friends literally since middle school i
mean um he's not trying to no no not him
he's out of the picture he's already
discredited himself he he doesn't even
work he's not he no longer gets a vote
because his opinion is dumb now let's
move on do you have any money
nah man i mean no money at all okay you
don't have any money in savings at all
i've got four hundred dollars okay i've
got the car did you total the forerunner
oh man it's uh
i mean it's running did you have did you
have insurance
uh i've got liability oh you didn't have
collision
okay so you just lost your car
and it's gonna sell broken for help for
eight grand
broken it'll i mean
so 8k was to was to
fix it oh fix it oh you're saying you
get quotes okay got it yeah you don't
have a grand though
no definitely not and you don't have
insurance to fix it so yeah before you
spend eight grand to fix this piece of
crap you'd spend eight grand to buy a
car but in either case you don't have
eight grand so let's start again uh you
have four hundred dollars to your name
i've got a credit card man but yeah i
know how you feel about where where's
your money going you said you're a
travel nurse that's good money
yeah so the way i mean it sounds real
real great you know but there's honestly
there's a period where you've you've
gotta make ends meet before your first
like your first pain like you get money
from from the uh agency
so um anyway i've i've
made
two i've gotten two paychecks so far and
um
after
paying back all the travel expenses and
and um
the the credit card i ended up getting
um um is the card paid off now do you
have a zero balance on it
uh-huh yep
and it will sell in its current
condition for how much
800 was what carmax told me
so you can get you got a thousand
dollars
to your name when do you get your next
check
yes
when do you get your next check
uh this is coming friday how much will
it be
2800
okay um
[Music]
all right i can only tell you what i
would do in your situation
you painted yourself into a really
difficult corner because you saved
absolutely no money and you didn't carry
collision insurance which you should
have been doing both of those things
okay
so today we're going to start listening
to dave and george and start doing this
stuff so your next goal is to get a
thousand dollars in the bank after we
get you a car
okay
but if i woke up in your shoes your back
is against the wall i'd sell the car for
800. i'd take a thousand of my 1200 i'd
take a thousand out of the check that's
coming friday and i'd buy a 2 000 car
i would drive that for two to three
months
meanwhile i'm gonna save like a crazy
man and buy an 8 000 car
and i want you to work like a freaking
maniac like every hour they will give
you
and i want you to quit partying
i lived it up a little bit on the way
here
there it is that's what i was waiting
for a little bit of honesty out of nick
yeah dave's exactly right uh the whole
idea that if you buy a beater car it's
gonna explode on the interstate that's
just a load of baloney and it's
justification my car i'm driving right
now cost me six thousand dollars and
i've been driving it for almost five
years and it's a beater but it runs it's
a honda so go get you ever left you out
no never left you stranded never not one
time so okay look for a good used car
that's reasonable right now and that's
not gonna be sweet for two grand two
thousand two thousand it's ugly but
reliable i wanted here's the thing nick
your situation is
you're you're painting in this corner
because you you're
you're living for the moment your entire
whole calendar and your checkbook is
yolo
it's every bit thank god it's friday oh
god it's monday and i want you to flip
that and start having a vision for your
life a decade from now the kind of man
you want to be
the kind of place you want to be
how you want to be living and the amount
of wealth you want to build
because if you keep living like you're
living you're going to keep having the
same problems you got
i noticed that when i was completely
broke that my life looked like a country
song
everything that can go wrong well keep
the dog out of the street it'll get hit
oh my god everything that can go wrong
well right
and that's what's happening to you
and it's because you've lived down to
the nub on everything
i mean you've left yourself no margin in
your schedule
and um you're living for the moment and
i it's nothing
i'm not shaming you i'm just telling you
how to fix this young man
and so uh
throw your shoulders back and let's say
i need a five year a 10 year vision for
my life and what are the steps for me to
get there and you can have enjoyment
along that journey as well
but in seeking enjoyment all the time
all you found is stress
yeah i mean there's a lot of that yellow
mentality happening here and like dave
said if you get that vision i mean sign
up for our building wealth live stream
and start to picture what would it be
like
five years from now 10 years from now
fully funded emergency fund maybe i'm
starting a family i've got money in the
bank i'm hitting my goals and i use this
moment as a never again moment where you
said never again am i gonna not have the
right insurance have four hundred
dollars to my name and have nothing to
show for my next we had a lady when hit
she moved to travel nursing and she had
350 000 of student loan debt
in 12 months she made 500 000
as a travel nurse working 80 hours a
week every coveted thing she could get
on
and yeah there's some risk to that i i'm
not a medical professional i'm just
admiring that she had a vision for her
life and went from deep in a hole and a
mess to 500 000 12 months later now she
quit
after that and went back and you can't
do that forever you should burn the
candle at both ends but for 12 months
she laid it on the line because she had
a vision for her life and said i'm never
going to be in this situation again
and um
and so maybe this car wreck
uh wakes you up
and maybe this is your your time that
you say never again
or maybe you keep living like you've
been living and you're gonna keep
getting what you've been getting my
brother
it's a reaping and sowing thing when you
plant corn don't be shocked corn grows
that's how this life works
you're a good man nick thank you for
calling in we're honored to talk to you
we appreciate you joining us in our in
our audience
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you